with tensions rising between Iran in the
United States Saudi Arabia is blaming
Iran for a drone strike that shut down
one of its oil pipelines the US has sent
military units to the Middle East after
alleged threats from Tehran senior
foreign affairs correspondent and Face
the Nation moderator Margot Brennan
spoke to Iran's UN Ambassador Margaret
good morning good morning well Iran's
leaders are skeptical of president
Trump's offer to talk in part because he
already withdrew from a diplomatic deal
with them yesterday the president told
his acting defense secretary that he
does not want war and I asked Iran's UN
Ambassador if that reassured him I
believe that President Trump does not
want a war
Iran's ambassador to the UN Majeed talks
revanche II told CBS News that he
believed president Trump's comments on
Thursday were genuine Raavan she accused
the u.s. of using flawed intelligence
and pointed to one key advisors past
support of the 2003 US invasion of Iran
you're talking about Ambassador Bolton I
don't want to name any names but but he
has been definitely one of one of the
person Raavan she flatly denied us
intelligence reports that an Iranian
commander ordered militias in Iraq to
prepare an attack on Americans there and
questioned whether the US has satellite
photos showing what analysts say are
containers for short-range ballistic
missiles being loaded on boats US
intelligence says they have evidence of
that do you deny that we do not fire
missiles out of small boats as long as
they cannot share those information with
the general public I think there is no
utility in in saying that these
information are credible behind closed
doors on Capitol Hill yesterday the
Trump administration shared that
classified intelligence with the
so-called gang of eight after the
briefing House Intelligence Committee
Chairman Adam Schiff said he feared a
clash the administration all along has
failed to articulate where their
strategy is supposed to lead but it
certainly appears to be leading leading
towards confrontation other members of
Congress will have to wait until next
Tuesday to receive a briefing
frustrating key work
publican allies I would tell the
administration you should pick up the
phone and call members of Congress so
that we don't have a microphone put in
her face ask us about why you're doing
something we have no clue Raavan she
blamed the US military buildup as one
reason his country is dismissing the
president's offer to have direct talks
why can't you get to a table to
negotiate they want to have this thing
in their hands trying to intimidate Iran
at the same time calling for a dialogue
what type of a dialog is this ambassador
Raavan she confirmed that Iran has been
in touch with Congress but declined to
say which offices now he is closed to
Iran's president and the Ambassador told
us he will soon fly back to Tehran to
discuss how to cool tensions Vlad lots
of saber rattling Margaret thank you
very much